un cambio temporal en la política de
incitación al odio me está permitirá a
los usuarios de facebook e instagram en
algunos países llamar a la violencia
contra los rusos o los soldados rusos en
el contexto de la invasión de ucrania e
incluso dejaría algunos post en los que
los usuarios piden la muerte del
presidente ruso vladimir putin y su
homólogo bielorruso alexander lukachenko
meta se pronunció a través de un
comunicado
como resultado de la invasión rusa de
ucrania hemos permitido temporalmente
formas de expresión política que
normalmente violarían nuestras normas
como el discurso violento como muerte
los invasores rusos según el informe de
reuters la medida aplicaría en una
docena de países como ucrania rusia y
naciones vecinas una determinación que
enfureció a moscú donde los fiscales han
pedido a un tribunal que designe a la
empresa como organización extremista
mientras que el portavoz del kremlin
dmitri peskov habló de sanciones más
severas
ciertamente confío en que nuestras
autoridades pertinentes investigarán si
realmente de cierto esperamos que no sea
así porque de ser cierto se requerirán
medidas más decisivas para poner fin a
las actividades de esta empresa
la semana pasada a moscú aseguró que iba
a prohibir a facebook en el país en
respuesta a lo que dijo que eran
restricciones de acceso a los medios de
comunicación rusos en la plata